over the past couple of days there've
been a bunch of hearings in the senate
over the debacle in afghanistan and it
is well worth pointing out that now
finally after you know we've been out of
there for about a month and 100
americans are still trapped behind enemy
lines minimum and thousands of green
card holders are trapped behind their
and tens of thousands of siv holders are
trapped behind enemy lines with the
taliban hanging people in central
squares in cities like herrat
and cutting off hands again and pushing
women back into the basement and all
that now we're finding out that this was
all a bad idea who could have thunk who
could have thunk
general milly the all-powerful almighty
general mark milley uh he came out and
said oh yeah we lost the war yeah no no
no bleep sherlock you did well done
there's a whole series of decisions that
take place over 20 years
i don't think that whenever you get some
phenomena like a war that is lost and it
has been in the sense of we accomplished
our strategic task of protecting america
against al qaeda but certainly the end
state is a whole lot different than what
we wanted so whenever the phenomena like
that happens there's an awful lot of
causal factors and we're gonna have to
figure that out
oh well i mean one of those causal
factors would have been the complete
withdrawal of american troops without
any sort of plan for upholding the
afghan military withdrawing all air
support withdrawing all civilian
contractors and then withdrawing the
military before any of the civilians
could leave maybe ha
i don't know just a guess i had a couple
of guesses there i think maybe some of
them are accurate then millie apparently
in a in a confidential briefing he
apparently directly blamed the state
department he said officials waited too
long to order the operation out of
kabul's airport
two days of testimony from millie
defense secretary lloyd austin and
general frank mckenzie head of centcom
underscore the finger-pointing and deep
divisions between state and the pentagon
lawmakers are demanding accountability
over the biden administration's chaotic
exit from afghanistan including the
failure to evacuate thousands of at-risk
afghan allies and leaving without
evacuating all americans the state
department delayed evacuations at the
order of president biden
after afghan president ashkaf ghani
warned that evacuating afghan allies
earlier would destroy morale and lead to
the collapse of the government
during a closed door session after
tuesday's public testimony senator tammy
duckworth directed a general question to
austin about lessons learned from the
withdrawal and milly jumped in to say
the evacuation of civilians needed to
happen earlier
so milly was like it wasn't us it was
the state department remember joe biden
said there was virtual unanimity inside
his administration his military folks
were just backing what he had to say
lies
and general milley also admitted in
testimony that the taliban never broke
affiliation with al-qaeda remember that
time they were saying that the taliban
was helping us fight al qaeda and fight
fight isis and they were really they're
moderating that was all lie
there were seven conditions
applicable to the taliban
and eight conditions applicable to the
united states
while the taliban did not attack u.s
forces which was one of the conditions
it failed to fully honor any
any other condition
under the doha agreement
and perhaps most importantly for u.s
national security
the taliban has never renounced al qaeda
or broke its affiliation with them
oh well um that's that's weird because
you know that might have been helpful
for the american people to know when you
surrendered the entire country to them
okay lloyd austin the incompetent
secretary of defense he uh he also
blamed the state department
was it your judgment and opinion that
the evacuations of civilians should have
begun before the middle of august
we provided our input to the state
department and again it is a call of the
state department to
i understand that i understand that mr
secretary i'm asking for what your your
judgment was we provided input to uh to
try to get out as many uh
uh
afghans who have helped us
uh along the way uh as
you know as early as possible uh but
again the state department uh has you
know made its decisions
oh interesting interesting how that
worked you know you didn't see any of
this in real time right in real time
they were all shoulder to shoulder
because your politicians lie to you
political appointees lie to you and just
because they're generals and they're at
the top of the hierarchy does not mean
they're not lying to you
okay
there's such a thing as political
generals
many of them get to the top of the
hierarchy specifically because they're
politically adept lloyd austin now
admitting oh yeah by the way terrorism
is a threat like as of right now from
afghanistan we were told that it was
like two three years away nope not right
now
al qaeda has been degraded over time
now terrorist organizations seek
ungoverned spaces so that they can
uh
train and and equip and thrive and and
so
there there is clearly a possibility
that that can happen here uh going
forward
and uh and meanwhile frank mckenzie head
of centcom remember who was praising the
taliban and he was talking about how
helpful they were throughout this entire
process um he admits that the taliban
offered the united states control over
kabul so we could evacuate people and
the united states turned it down at the
best of the biden administration they
said no no we only want kabul airport
well only 13 um american service members
had to die for that particular decision
here's ken mckenzie
who made the uh the decision to turn
down the taliban offer to allow the u.s
military to secure kabul and put the
safety of our troops in the hands of the
taliban i did not consider that to be a
formal offer and it was not the reason
why i was there so i did not pursue it
so if you're if someone actually made a
decision that would have been me so we
don't know if it was conveyed to the
president we don't know i do know what
was conveyed to my chain of command
okay it was conveyed with chain of
command he just decided oh well what
by the way jin saki now admitting by the
way the generals did in fact want troops
there when joe biden was out there lying
to us saying all of his generals were in
agreement with him that was obviously
untrue at the time and some of us were
pointing out he was lying at the time
here's jon sackey admitting he was lying
at the time
what we're talking about here was an
initial recommendation in the short
initial period of time of having a true
presence that would continue not a
surprise the recommendation over the
course of the last 20 years from the
military has been to maintain a troop
presence you could argue that's their
job to to maintain that the president's
view when given when making a risk
assessment when when reviewing his
options was that he did not want to
escalate the number of troops we had in
afghanistan he did not want to risk
losing more troops he did not want to go
back at war with the taliban okay so
bottom line it was biden's call even
while biden was blaming everybody else
what a bleep show this administration is
i mean truly and honestly it is such a
bleep show and here's the thing joe
biden right that's he not old guy what's
waiting in the wings is way worse than
joe biden and kamala harris is way worse
than joe biden this is why democrats
have to be in a state of low-level panic
that is quickly rising to high
high-level panic i mean they're moving
from defcon 3 to about defcon 2 right
now because if they end up with kamala
harris as a candidate in 2024 after this
bleepshoven administration they are in
serious serious trouble how bad is como
harris by the way kamala harris is so
bad at this that yesterday she was
confronted by a student at some sort of
speech and the students started just
spewing anti-semitic garbage about
israel they said saying that israel was
involved in a quote-unquote ethnic
genocide okay which is just an
anti-semitic lie it's just a jew-hating
lie it is there's no support for it and
kamala harris because she's incompetent
and terrible at this immediately granted
a credence
over the summer there have been like
protests and demonstrations and
astronomical numbers standing with
palestine but then just a few days ago
there were funds allocated to continue
backing israel which hurts my heart
because it's
an ethnic genocide and the displacement
of people the same that happened in
america
okay and kamala harris nods well that is
happening and then she suggested quote
i'm glad you did about this girl asking
the question i'm glad you did i'm glad
you did again this is about the fact
that your voice your perspective your
experience your truth should not be
suppressed
whoo okay so that's waiting in the wings
for the democrats no wonder they are in
a state of panic they should be they
should be this administration is here's
the thing whether or not they pass this
bipartisan infrastructure bill whether
or not they pass this budget bill
they've got a major problem on their
hands and they should they're bad at
governing their ideas are wrong and
their politicians are both
incompetent
and and poor at their actual
public-facing jobs
all of which
you know says that there is not a bright
future for this particular
administration
we're in a battle for the culture and
for our values like and subscribe to
help keep our videos on the front line
of the fight and top of your feet